this weekend
the briggs will wear the 1974 uniform in
honor of phil negro and hank aaron
a uniform
both men wore during their time as
players for the atlanta braves
and throughout the season the braves
will wear their uniform numbers 35 and
44 on their caps
and reverent respect to the legends we
lost
it's charlie morton versus zach wheeler
a rematch of a terrific game played up
at citizens bank park in philadelphia
last week charlie threw well up in
philadelphia i felt like you know you'd
like to see him a little crisper today
maybe get you into the sixth seventh
inning
and look for the whole team as a whole
win the home opener first time you've
had fans back in with you go win the
opener hoskins then harper for philly
the pitch tipped and caught by darnold
hoskins is out on strikes as is
customary hoskins complains but
apparently that ball was in the glove
not on the ground two outs
and al hoskins barking with carlos
torres the home pit umpire joe girardi
wants to
get some help now good curveball
definitely hit the ground yep you'll
take them when you can get them
absolutely standing boo for bryce harper
who knew it was coming if he strikes it
out this place is going to explode
here's the one two on the way
right down broadway at the knees charlie
morton back-to-back strikeouts and a
one-two-three start in his old vulcan
for the braves no score here in the
bottom of the first inning and wheeler
gets to work zach last year 11 starts
has made one start this season 10
strikeouts and seven innings in that
start against the braves two runners on
with two outs
they throw back to second base and they
got freddie freeman
unbelievable pick by jt and throw this
is this is where his athleticism is
uh
unmatched
he he made an unbelievable play right
here picking it and throwing behind
t-mac this this catcher is almost like a
short stop playing that flame behind the
plate two balls two strikes it's gotten
the count even again against dansby
swanson no score bottom of the second
there are no leads off of first
at a colt strike three right on the
outside part of the plate first
strikeout for wheeler that was perfectly
placed he absolutely could have done at
nothing with this pitch at all it was
perfectly placed on the outer corner the
bottom part of the zone he threw three
straight went back to the well again and
looks like he's found a pitch that he
feels comfortable with now
wheeler nods yes to jt comes set with
the sign and the o2
breaking ball what a call strike three
two strikeouts of the inning for zach
wheeler
no runs no hits one man left pitch all
the way to gene segura oak two
ground ball shortstop nice sliding play
by dansby swanson to his feet not in
time the hustling gene segora able to
beat it out for the first hit of the day
for the fills and he's been doing this
thompson spring training i mean he's
been busting it uh from the from the
very beginning uh of the games early in
in even in february and he got out of
the box really well as one of those
pitches that he had to lean out to try
to to get and he was on his way running
right out of the chute and really busted
it great job
paisley taken eighth overall in 2017 out
of the university of virginia o2 pitch
got him swinging
three straight curve balls from charlie
morton
mccutchen grounded out his first time up
let's go for a little two-out thunder
here
little looper out to right field that's
going to drop in for a base hit sagore's
around third he's heading home he'll
score it's an rbi single for mccutchen
and the phillies are on top one to
nothing it's amazing how the little
things do actually count mary saskins
the batter a ball and two strikes
nothing wrong with that that paints the
outside half
a fastball freezes hoskins and they're
strikeout number five for morton later
pitching carefully to acunas full count
and a line drive over third that's
headed for the left field corner acuna
around first on his way to second
mccutcheon tries to dig it out and does
and ronald acuna jr has the braves first
hit at home
a ringing double into the left field
corner
well great at that
seven pitches
look at that fastball in the inner half
[Applause]
and you see ronald pull those hands and
kevin sites have been saying that's the
pitch he's been working on
is pulling those hands in the inside
fastball's probably if you
talk about ronald his one weakness
hit a double in washington on that same
pitch the other day now double tonight
oh into the count
and he threw it again and wheeler knew
it seven strikeouts for charlie morton
he'll go to work next in a one-run game
see if charlie can get on to lead off
the inning
look at charlie
little payback for wheeler i'm not
saying a word
tom i
sometimes you got to take batters into
your own hands
[Laughter]
look at that just going the other way
no he wasn't late he went with it
you can't teach that you can't
pitcher starts the inning with a hit
let's see if that opens the offensive
floodgates for the braves they're down a
run
swung on hit high and deep to center
way back that ball is gone home run
2-1 atlanta
i've waited 19 months to say it fellas
listen to this crowd
that ball is absolutely hammered
just right of chattahoochee falls about
15 rows up
and glad you called it
she's put in the seats i mean you know i
saw the took was a pitcher to get the
rebels started
and you're right chip though how great
is that with fans guys you didn't see
that excitement last year in the dugout
after a home run
i'll tell you what this
crowd is loud man
cement mixer slider
that's usually what happens
he knew it too god i hope he did
114 off the bat braves have the lead and
now ozzie yanks one down the line
ricochet off the fence here goes ozzy
the second he'll
get there ahead of the throw three
straight atlanta hits in the inning
man look at this ball at the end guys
just hit the edge if that doesn't i
wanted to that was he was going three
ozzie with a good lead at second two out
oh and two darno breaking ball line
drive into left-center field here comes
ozzie around third to score darno got an
0-2 pitch to hit and he extends the lead
it's 3-1
you don't see that happen to wheeler too
often it hasn't happened this year
great piece of hitting by travis so the
braves right-hander charlie morton needs
to get boom and get out of this sixth
inning
he drives this one to right county back
still going register and makes the play
wow do it all ronald boom can't believe
it thought he had it over acuna's head
but ronald tracked it down on the
warning track a guy that fits in very
well we're told
with the braves culture in that locker
room one ball two strikes
swing fly ball that's well hit harper
back can you believe it another pitch
hit homer
the braves now lead it six to one
i think a big discussion coming in guys
was the power off the bench where the
brain's gonna have any power
seven games in you got three home runs
braves had the bench one pinch hit homer
last year they've got three in the first
week two balls in a strike
fly ball well hit harper on the run not
getting mad freddy hits one out
well he jumped in
and a big one
[Applause]
into and out of the glove of that
phillies fan whose dad is letting him
have it how can you drop that
oh then he dropped it again oh dad's all
over him
dad says it's my fault he's trying to
get the baseball to watch dad shaking
his head puts the hoodie on i don't want
to be seen with this
double play ball might end the game
there's one
there it is double play bravo's win the
home opener they're 5-0 in the first
home game of the season in the history
of truest park
guys charlie morton was outstanding
braves bullpen was great and ronald
lacuna one word wow